يبدو ان تقدم الروسيه في حمله للسلع على
مدينه بخموت الواقعه بشكل اوكرانيا قد
تعثر وفقا لما ذكرته احدى المؤسسات
البحثيه الرائده في تقييم اطول معركه بريه
في الحرب معهد دراسه الحرب ومقره في
واشنطن افاد بانه لا يوجد تقدم مؤكد
للقوات الروسيه في ضخمه وان قوات الروسيه
وصلت شان هجمات بريه في المدينه لكن لا
دليل حتى اللحظه على انها تمكنت بالفعل من
احراز اي تقدم وياتي تقليل معهد دراسه
الحرب بعد رواج مزاعم عن تقدم الروسي في
وقت سابق هذا الاسبوع وفيما تستمر المعارك
العنيفه في مدينه بحمود شرق اوكرانيا اقر
قائد القوات البريه الاوكساندرسيسكي ان
الاوضاع في المدينه صعبه جدا مجددا في
الوقت عينه على ان قوته تصدت لكل
المحاولات الروسيه لاستيلاء على بخموت عبر
المدفعيه والدبابات والقوى الناريه الاخرى
في المقابل اعلن الكريم على لساني ناطق
باسميه انه لا يمكن تحقيق اهداف روسيا في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه الا بالعمل العسكري
وان المسارى السلمي للوضع في اوكرانيا
مستبعد حاليا